video we'll be talking about the process
of neurulation this is a process by
which the neural tube forms and this is
the blueprint for the human
brain one of the major events in the
third week is the gastrulation that
means the formation of three different
germ layer so let us begin our journey
from this particular stage so from the
aplast three different germ layers are
formed namely ectoderm mesoderm and
endoderm from these three germ layers
ectoderm is the layer which would form
the central nervous system and the brain
mesoderm and endoderm forms other
systems so here we need to focus on
ectoderm now the major event that
happens at the end of the third week is
the neural induction which is the key
subprocess within the ne neurulation so
in this case the pr primtive node
induces the overlapping new ectoderm to
form the neural plate or neuroectoderm
so obviously NE the neural tube is
actually derived from the ectoderm the
entire nervous system is derived from
the ectoderm the notocord actually
induces formation of these ectoderm to
become neuroectoderm and that's the
rudimentary nervous system so this is
around day
18 this is how the embryo will look like
from a top
view so this is the cranial end and this
is the codal end around day 21 so you
can see this nowhere looks like a brain
at that this particular point of time
but believe me eventually this would
give rise to the embrionic brain so the
ectoderm which is present on both the
sides of this midline would eventually
close like this particular Arrow
Direction and it would form the neural
tube at on day 22 one can clearly see
the middle portion of these uh sheet is
actually closed and formed a tube but
both ends of this particular sheet is
not closed properly yet so these are
known as cranial neuropore and the
cordal neuropore eventually in order to
form that tube these two portions need
to be closed properly at around day
24 the cranial neuropore should be
closing
and in this closing procedure there are
nutrients which are super important such
as the folic acid or vitamin B9 without
vitamin B9 this closure cannot happen
and that is why folic acid deficiency is
detrimental folic acid is required in
the first month of the pregnancy before
even sometimes the woman W won't know
that she is pregnant but folic acid is
really important for the neural tube
closure so the cranial neuropore closes
around day 24 and the codal neuropore
closes around day 28
approximately and if this closure
doesn't happen properly then it might
lead to problems like anany or
spinabifida both are neural tube defects
which lead to severe defects in the
nervous
system that is why every woman who wants
to conceive should consider taking 400
microgr of folic acid on a daily basis
and it's true because if you look at the
global map the third world countries are
more affected where vitamin or mineral
or nutrition is a big problem whereas
the incidence of neural tube defects are
less common in case of the developed
world now if the cranial end of the
neurot tube fails to close there are
many defects like anany the baby is born
without the significant part of its
brain then there is inany which leads to
a extreme retroflexion of the head there
is also known there there are defects
also known as an
Nal which is very hard to pronounce but
anyway in this
case the in the case of osil the sac is
basically a sa like protrusion is found
in the back of the head there is also
another defect which is very hard to
pronounce but known as crano ricus casis
in this case what happens is the entire
brain cranial Vault spinal cord
everything is absent this is very severe
the babies doesn't survive the less
severe forms happens when there is a
defect in the Cod End closing there
could be open and close form of
spinabifida where there are protusion of
the spinal column either uh the nerve or
the skin is exposed in the backside of
the baby
so all these things happens due to the
deficiency of uh vitamin B12 and defects
in neural tube
closure now let's look at the neural
tube closure from a cross-sectional view
now we are not looking at the embryo
from the top view we are looking at it
from the cross-sectional view here are
the three germ layers and mind that this
is the Noto cord Noto cord secretes
several factors morphogens importantly
Sonic Hedgehog these things actually
induce
the ectoderm which is just above it and
this ectoderm is now termed as
neuroectoderm this is still an ectoderm
but these cells has different properties
different adhesion properties among
themselves different molecular markers
so this is the region which eventually
give rise to the neural tube so this
particular region is also known as
neural plate and this formation or this
induction is happening within the time
period of day 18 to day
20 now after that a Groove would be
formed this particular Groove that you
can see here is known as the neural
Groove because the neural plate begins
to invaginate and this forms a dimple a
Groove in the center that is the neural
Groove eventually two sides of this
neural Groove would come closer and
closer till the point it Fus together to
form the neural tube now you can see the
neural tube formation is almost done and
at this particular point at around day
uh
28 this should be complete and at this
point of time one can see this is the
neural tube which would eventually give
rise to central nervous system brain and
the spinal CL cord and this is the
neural crest cells these are specialized
group of cells which are capable of
giving rise to many cell types including
cells of the peripheral nervous system
in a different video we'll talk about
the neural cells in details but right
now we are focusing on the process of
neurulation so this was the overview
about neurulation now we are going to
delve into the cellular details of
neurogenesis so this is the top view and
the cross-sectional view together so
this is the neural plate induction then
neural group formation eventually neural
group the edges of the neural group come
close to each other till the time they
fuse and this is how the neural tube is
generated now if you don't understand
this process so far let me give you an
analogy of a paper so roughly our
nervous system which is formed from the
neural tube is basically a pipe a pipe
with disproportionate diameter at
different locations so you can imagine
the brain side is a thicker pipe whereas
the spinal cord is a a thinner pipe
anyway it's a pipe so in that case the
development happens from a sheet so how
do you make a pipe from a sheet you have
to curl the pipe curl the sheet to form
the pipe so imagine your folding this
particular sheet and forming this tube
and exactly that's what happens in the
neural tube development so this is the
fundamental of new
relation now let's get back to the
cellular details so this is the neural
tube which is already uh the folding
happened the closure happened now if we
zoom into the neural tube we would see
there are cell types which are known as
neuroepithelial cells these
neuroepithelial cells are actually stem
cells which has the capability of self
renewal they divide and give rise to
daughter cells which are exactly
identical and these neuroepithelial
cells are actually ually giving rise to
the neurons but in a sequential fashion
so this is how it happens so
neuroepithelial cells are the precursors
for the radial Gia So eventually
neuroepithelial cells would change their
shape and size their adition properties
and become radial gal cells so these
neuroepithelial cells and Radial gal
cells look quite different as the
picture shows not only that these
neuroepithelial cells are
undifferentiated and they're lining the
entire neural tube and they are they are
stem cells they are stem in nature
whereas the radial cells are one type of
specialized neuroepithelial cell they
also have the stem cell like property
but they can give rise they can either
divide symmetrically or asymmetrically
as well now these neural uh epithelial
cells or radial gal cells in the human
brain shows a typical cell migration
behavior and this cell migration
behavior is known as interkinetic
nuclear movement in order to understand
the process of interkinetic move uh cell
movement or the cell division during the
uh generation of these radial gal cells
we have to take a step back and try to
understand this Dynamic process now we
are looking at one section of the early
embryonic brain and at that point of
time of development you can see the
brain looks pretty smooth from the
beginning of the uh velopment the brain
is not convoluted and garfied it is
initially smooth eventually gyrification
happens so now you can see these cells
which are radial gal cells and look how
these cell bodies change their position
with respect to the ventricular surface
and the pl surface while they divide
they divide into two radial Gia
eventually these two radial Gia are each
able to divide and give rise to more
radial Gia so this is how the radial Gia
are actually
moving up and down during this
particular uh process of neurulation now
let us try to understand this process in
bit more details so this is how a radial
Gia look like in the interphase so this
is the G1 phase you can note the cell
body of the radial Gia is up above from
the ventricular surface it is quite
above the ventricular surface the at the
S phase it is quite close to the pl
surface but from G1 from G2 phase these
cell bodies start descending downwards
you can see at PR metaphase and even at
metaphase the cell bodies are exactly
touching the ventricular surface so this
is one peculiar um movement that happens
during this process so the metaphysic
cell bodies exactly lines to The
ventricle when they are about to divide
so this
metaphysic particular radial Gia would
eventually touch the ventric rular
surface it would undergo anaphase and
eventually cyesis then ultimately it
would give rise to two daughter cells
each of these daughter cells can divide
symmetrically in the initial phase of
the nervous system development the
divisions are more symmetric that leads
to a more number of stem cells this is
known as Transit amplification that
means if you have uh you have you have
to invest somewhere you have to first
amplify your money this is how n system
stem increase the number of stem cells
before giving rise to the neurons so now
these radial gal progenitors which are
born from the mother now would extend
their processes towards the pl surface
again the same division process would
repeat you can see the cell bodies are
now moving towards the ventricular
surface and the mhase happens when they
touch the ventricular surface and now
they divides and give rise to again
other daughter cells this is how the
overall process of uh self renewal
division takes place in the initial
portion of the nervous in initial time
point of the nervous system now after a
point of time when there are substantial
number of neuronal stem cells then it's
time to give rise to neuron this process
is known as
neurogenesis in this case the radial Gia
can give rise to neurogenic division so
they can give rise to one neuron marked
here in green
and one radial glea so this is a
asymmetric division instead of a
symmetric division now when the time
progresses after a point of time after
giving rise to substantial number of
neuron the radial gal progenitor would
eventually produce gal cells such as the
astrocytes how this temporal
coordination is regulated in the brain
is still debatable and a big question
but the key essence of gliogenesis and
the neurogenesis is time and external
and internal
influences now this is a particular
timeline which would quickly summarize
the process of cell birth in the uh
brain development process so here is
gestational week you can see the neur
relation happens at very early stage
within the five fifth week of the uh
gestation then there is neurogenesis
there is micro Invasion microglia are
not born from neuronal stem cells they
are coming from the mesodermal lineage
they inate the brain then there is
astrogliogenesis and after astrogenesis
there is oligodendrogenesis
and synaptogenesis happens somewhere
around gestational week 16 and continues
even after the birth and it is modified
or synap synapse Genesis is modified
based on experience and external
stimuli now let us quickly look at some
terminology at around gw3 or gational
week 3 this is the basic blueprint of
the brain you can see the the red
portion is known as the for brain or
prens ailon the green portion is known
as the mlon and the yellow portion is
known as the hind brain or the romen
sealon so this is a broad demarcation of
the three regions in the
brain now at around
gw7 we can see that there would be
further uh
subdivision of these regions for example
proen cilon would give rise to tensilon
and dilon romen seyon give rise to
metencephalon and milen sealon so now we
can understand complication and more
intricate architecture is building up as
the time progresses at around
gw12 telencephalon give rise to cerebral
hemispheres which are responsible for
higher cognitive processing and function
dianon form forms and give rise to the
structures like Thalamus and
hypothalamus which are involved in
sensory processing homeostasis Etc then
in the romlon metan sephon give rise to
structures like pawns and cereum which
are essential for motor coordination and
fine-tuning balance then Mylon actually
give rise to medula oblongata which is
involved in autonomic functions like
breathing heart rate control Etc so now
we understand how the nervous system is
getting from simple to complicated now
this particular stage of formation of
these specifical re region region is
known as vesicularization so basic
vesicles are forming in the brain which
would eventually be uh regionalized into
specific brain region so this kind of
summarize our overall idea about
neurulation eventually we would focus on
corticogenesis that how cortex is formed
how telencephalic or dilic development
takes place from this stage and that
happens within a long period of time
with the influence of external and
internal factors many cells are
interplaying with each other with the
signaling Pathways to make it happen
this is not a simple process but I hope
this video was simple enough to
understand if you like this video give
it a quick thumbs up get more notes and
flash cards in our Instagram and
Facebook page you can support our
Channel using PayPal PTM or UPI see you
in next
video